women's boss it's so funny how they use
boss babe I was thinking about this I'm
like you're telling me an only fans
model is your idea of a woman crushing
the patriarch
really you know and I think that this is
going to be and I'm not even going to
say rather right or wrong this is going
to be a solution that you guys are going
to see women are going to date the
jacked trainers um that's what I call
them like the personal trainer
relationship where the guys will date
the woman that's like a lawyer and I was
thinking when I said this I was thinking
of like a lawyer like a Wall Street
chick but only fans models too that's
what you're going to see um men are
funny they're funny creatures they'll if
there's a game they're going to figure
out the easiest way to play it